dis-donc escamilla la troisième entre 10
et 20 centimètres avec toi à moi j'ai
mis au travail tranche avant oui ce
mieux à 30 cm ouais remarques faut bien
ça au et tu seras elle n'aime pas les
cravates courte non c'est pas la même
alors après alors si vous avez une
maladie sexuellement transmissible
alors petit à vous vous abstenez de
toute rencontre petit b vous en parlez à
votre partenaire
juste avant on peut je lui en parle
juste après après c'est dommage de
gâcher quoi alors après comment
l'abordez-vous
petit à jean voit une lettre romantique
et un bouquet de roses petit b je lui
met la main aux fesses dans le métro
oui parce que on n'a pas toujours des
tas en plus annoncé aussi d'être plus
pratique
c'est dire que moi normalement gma
gabardine ah oui mon projet n'est pas
trop je préfère une rue tu vois un peu
plus calme oui bah ouais mais c'est pas
écran maintenant bon malherbe est
d'accord alors vous êtes dans un lieu
public
on reste que les femmes vous regarde
petit a immédiatement petit b au bout de
cinq minutes
petit c'est pas du tout bon renard que
des fois il peut y avoir deux trois
minutes
oui oui 4 5 minutes cinq civils et six
un jour alors ses remarques une fois on
nous a regardé trop quand on pique
[ __ ] devant le sex-shop devant
l'attroupement
ouais y avait une femme je rêvais
voilà c'est alors le calme est trop
criant oui
alors dans les rapports amoureux qui
prend l'initiative alors petit à vous
petit b votre femme c'est nous concerne
pas tu te vois avec une femme qui te
prend l'initiative couleurs ja je n'ai
rien pour nous annonce que d'amener un
week-end petit à deauville petit b val
d'isere petit c'est à cannes on est
aussi bien en banlieue
omar wade fois jamais le voir un clip
est la télé alors lorsque vous jouez au
tennis en pépites à vous l'a laissé
gagner petit b vous vous défendez
jusqu'à la balle de match
le tennis c'est le truc de la télé les
mac avec des raquettes là ouais ouais
ouais on est potes étaient des rebelles
non mais qu'est ce qu'on m'a jamais rien
prouvé ou la hausse et des tests pour
les français moyens nous
année des artistes oui parce que moi tu
vois comment dire mon style séducteur ce
serait plutôt discret moi je préfère
rien faire en fait ouais ouais mais ça
marche
non non non ne marche pas dans les toits
moi mon truc c'est de faire rire ah oui
ça marche
non je n'ai moore spécial bons à
batailler encore une que ça j'aurais
sectorielle vous d'avoir des rapports
avec un autre os au brésil
remarque oui oui est ce que tu fais
après le sketch on se voit oui